Dark Souls 3 is finally gracing consoles
and PCs everywhere but unfortunately
ashen ones playing on their personal
computers have run into some trouble if
you've experienced early game crashes
here's the good news a steam user by the
name of Alya Dan Ward has found a
temporary fix according to ward the
crashes are caused by a lighting glitch
which triggers as you approach a bonfire
to avoid this your best bet is to drop
the lighting option to its lowest
possible setting alternatively you can
make your character wear a helmet
although the only way to do this so
early in the game is to start with the
night class these solutions aren't
guaranteed to work but at this point
they're definitely your best option
these are only temporary solutions but
publisher Namco Bandai is aware of the
problem and is reportedly working on a
permanent fix hopefully those of you who
encountered the crash will get to
experience Dark Souls 3 for what it
truly is after all we did give it an 8
out of 10 in the meantime you can stick
with GameSpot for all the Dark Souls
news you need